I've always loved medieval history I
always wanted to do something that was
in the space with Knights and fire
something that was dark that combine
magic something of the classic horror
storytelling elements but something that
was very different for me the original
concept was never tainted from start to
finish it was made by a Dark Souls fan
Eli Roth himself we had a lot of
creative freedom on this project it was
really fun to do something different and
do something really bold this project is
championed and featuring Eli raw and
Dark Souls is just a dream project for
us
the guiding point for us was to tell a
great story we left it to Namco to tell
us where we were going too far outside
of the Dark Souls universe they weren't
telling us the secrets of the game
they just said Dark Souls 3 this is what
happened he wanted to go ahead it's
about a knight who's searching for
something and things go south pretty
quickly for our hero the battle is
finished fire is still smoking the ashes
are still smoldering and then he comes
in and he sees these three witches they
invite him to sit down and they say
drink and he steps in as soon as he
steps in that's his mistake right out
the back you I pitched his concept it
was dark it was creepy it was this rule
I came in sat down pitch the idea and
they went wow great we loved it this is
exactly in the tone of Dark Souls to get
into the Dark Souls universe you got to
play the game so he played a lot of Dark
Souls one Dark Souls 2 just to kind of
get into the world and try and interpret
some of the design elements of like
buildings architecture hallways overall
look for the piece we had a lot of
reference from Namco you tried
incorporating that with Eli Roth's nest
egg
he's had some great input reference for
backgrounds reference for characters the
animators are really down to collaborate
as soon as I said what if crows packing
out the eyes everyone did that in the
sky and then coming down and that's
always the funnest stuff to animate I
love working with a team it's not just
hey I have this idea everybody executes
it it's a you have an idea and you have
to inspire a team of artists all serving
this one greater story
see Eli's vision come to life every
aspect of the way it's been a very
rewarding process first designs and
you're excited about the designs and
then you get to see them move and their
sound effects and you're excited about
that and then you're putting the
finishing touches at every stage we've
been more and more excited and that's
such a good sign you know I've never had
this kind of experience before an AAMCO
is just amazing I mean they really
really wanted to do something cool and
innovative the pencil mileage alone was
pretty intimidating but we roasted the
occasion being a fan of the franchise
myself I think the fans are gonna enjoy
this we were able to really come up with
whatever aesthetic we wanted we tried to
steer to feel like it was in Dark Souls
universe it's a game that I love and now
that I've done this and it's gone so
well I really want to do it more this
was really really fun
you